zwei oder drei wochen der shutdown soll
wohl verlängert werden die bundesländer
streiten noch über die dauer
schlappe für donald trump zum ersten mal
in seiner amtszeit wird der us-präsident
vom senat überstimmt und gut fürs klima
teuer für verbraucher der neue co2 preis
lässt die kosten für sprit gas und
heizöl deutlich steigen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wir auch norbert könig
für den sport schon genommen der
shutdown solle über den zehnter januar
hinaus zwei bis drei wochen verlängert
werden das meldet die frankfurter
sonntagszeitung darauf hätten sich bund
und länder heute in einer telefonschalte
zur vorbereitung ihres treffens am
dienstag geeinigt vor allem die
besonders stark betroffenen länder
plädierten für die längere frist bis 31
januar heißt es unterdessen wächst die
kritik an der impfstoff strategie der
bundesregierung volker chat berichtet
sachsen ist spitze und wird es doch
nicht sein denn die korona werte steigen
ungebrochen
341 zwei neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner innerhalb einer woche acht
185,4 allein im vogtlandkreis die
bevölkerung auch ein wenig ratlos
verhalten doch der wind groß ist seine
treffen familien er sich viele
eigenheime gibt es hier
und ich habe auch einige bekannte die
erkrankt sind im altersheim
ich kann mir nicht erklären und ich
glaub es auch nicht erleichterungen
caritas heim kaarst bei düsseldorf der
arzt es da viele der 90 bewohner wollen
sich heute gegen korona impfen lassen
das impf tempo geht vielen in
deutschland zu langsam
jetzt hat sich ein mitglied der
nationalen akademie der wissenschaften
leopoldina zu wort gemeldet die neuro
immunologin frauke zipp wirft der
bundesregierung versäumnisse vor
ich halte die derzeitige situation für
grobes versagen der verantwortlichen
warum hat man im sommer nicht viel mehr
impfstoff auf risiko bestellt es gab
diese angebote wir hätten sie jetzt zur
verfügung
die weihnachtsfeiertage haben keine
entlastung gebracht zehn prozent mehr
patienten auf den intensivstationen als
vor zehn tagen viele ärzte wollen einen
shutdown über den zehnten januar
in den krankenhäusern ist es ja leider
auch so dass auch personal selber an
cupid 19 erkrankt wir also mit weniger
personal mehr patienten behandeln müssen
insofern sind wir der meinung die
einschränkungen die kontakt
beschränkungen müssen verlängert werden
die impfung bringt keine schnelle hilfe
nach einschätzung der ärztekammer wird
die zeit der belastung noch mindestens
zwei bis vier monate andauern
gunther love energy in berlin am
dienstag beraten bund und länder wie es
nach dem zehnten januar weitergeht und
offenbar sollen die beschränkung
tatsächlich um zwei bis drei wochen
verlängert werden was ist da dran
tatsächlich geht es jetzt natürlich hier
so langsam wieder los nach den
feiertagen ja wir an den dienstag ran
kommen desto höher wird auch die
schlagzahl der beratung zwischen bund
und ländern und es hat heute nachmittag
eine sitzung gegeben eine zweistündige
und zwar des chefs der staatskanzleien
der bundesländer
die haben sich untereinander schon mal
abgestimmt die müssen ja auch beschlüsse
vorbereiten
gemeinsam mit dem bund und die tendenz
ist ganz klar das hat man in den letzten
tagen auch schon gehört egal wer da aus
den bundesländern angesprochen wurde es
hieß immer eine eine abkürzung oder eine
eine verlängerung ist eigentlich
notwendig wenn man sich die fallzahlen
und auch die todeszahlen jetzt aktuell
anschaut und in diese richtung wird es
wohl gehen allerdings ist man sich noch
nicht einig über die länge und das ist
nicht der einzige punkt über den noch
diskutiert werden muss der große
knackpunkt ist die frage wie geht man
mit schulen und kitas um muss ein
bisschen die weiter geschlossen bleiben
muss es der bundesweite regelungen geben
auch da gibt es unterschiede je nach dem
wie die länder betroffen sind also da
gibt es noch viel gesprächsbedarf es
muss man sich auch noch die chefs der
bundesländer zusammen setzen und da wird
es noch weitere gespräche bis dienstag
geben
es bleibt also spannend dankeschön nach
berlin chuck unter labbadia
die korona zahlen in deutschland
scheinen zu sinken allerdings sind die
zahlen nach wie vor unvollständig weil
während der feiertage weniger getestet
wird und nicht alle gesundheitsämter
ihre daten übermitteln
das robert koch institut meldet 12 1690
neue infektionen innerhalb eines tages
336 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus
und wie kommt deutschland bei der
impfung voran online auf zdf heute
in unserer zdf heute app erfahren sie
welches bundesland bereits wie viele
menschen geimpft hat
in großbritannien begann die impfung
früher als bei uns dort haben schon eine
million menschen die erste dosis
bekommen
große sorgen bereitet allerdings die
mutierte und möglicherweise noch
ansteckender virus variante sie könnte
ursache seien für die hohen
infektionszahlen seit vier tagen werden
täglich 50.000 neue corona fälle
gemeldet
aus london andreas stamm normale
stationen umrüsten zur intensivstation
alltag im londoner university college
krankenhaus verhindern dass die korona
patienten nicht mehr behandeln können
bis die neue station einsatzbereit ist
erklärt einer der ärzte sei kein bett
mehr frei in den krankenhäusern im
südwesten englands überall das gleiche
bild die belastungsgrenze ist erreicht
oder gar überschritten wie in einem
wettbewerb zu entscheiden er ein
beatmungsgerät bekommt und wer nicht
dafür hat niemand diesen beruf gewählt
das emotionale trauma für die das tun
müssen ist schrecklich niemand sollte
das machen aber wir sind an diesem punkt
warten auf fluren oder behandlungsort
krankenwagen großen anteil an den stark
steigenden infektionszahlen habe die
neue virus mutation die zuerst im süden
englands auftauchte eine studie des
imperial college bestätigt erste
analysen die mutation seit deutlich
ansteckender der anstieg des wertes um
bis zu 0,7 hat im november lockt und
plötzlich dazu geführt dass die
fallzahlen nicht wie erwartet um 30
prozent gesunken sind sondern sich
verdreifacht haben das ist die
gravierendste mutation seit beginn der
epidemie
umso bedeutender ab montag wird der
zweite freigegebene impfstoff der von
astrazeneca eingesetzt gleichzeitig
ändert großbritannien seine strategie
die notwendige zweite impfdosis wird
statt nach drei wochen nun erst nach
drei monaten verabreicht um mehr
menschen impfen zu können auch wenn der
schutz bei einer dosis erst mal geringer
ist weder die hersteller noch die
zulassungsbehörden haben das getestet
was zeigt
wie ernst die lage ist frankreich und
corona das heißt inzwischen auch rund
65.000 tote
und dennoch nehmen viele das virus
offenbar immer noch nicht ernst wie
diese bilder zeigen rund 2500 menschen
feiern tanzen dicht gedrängt und
überwiegend ohne masken eine illegale
silvesterparty in der bretagne was zwei
tage dauert es bis die polizei die feier
auflöst nur ein beispiel dafür dass im
kampf gegen das virus in frankreich
vieles nicht rund läuft thomas walde
es ist eine party die im ganzen land
nach halt zweieinhalb tausend raver im
westfranzösischen jurong feiern bis die
polizei kommt und sogar noch etwas
länger
erst nach 2 durchtanzten nächten können
die behörden verkünden dass der spaß
vorbei ist love but i do die rave party
von juror ist beendet sie hat 36 stunden
gedauert es war eine illegale
veranstaltung die ich verboten hatte und
für die wir viele kräfte aufgeboten
haben publizistisches juli zwei hatte
früh versucht die versammlung zu stoppen
aber angesichts der großen
teilnehmerzahl hatte sie nicht genügend
kräfte mehr als 1200 bußgelder hat die
polizei heute verhängt zuvor hatten sich
die feiern denn weder von der pandemie
noch von der sperrstunde aufhalten
lassen vytorin sich ist gut organisiert
es gibt ordentlich was zu essen selbst
aus dem ausland sind leute gekommen
trotz weniger gut organisiert ist
derweil der kampf gegen die pandemie im
land bislang sind gerade mal einige
hundert menschen gegen kuwait geimpft
worden war danny impfen deutlich
langsamer als in unseren impfstoff es
dauerte zehn monate hin zu entwickeln da
sonst wenig drei jahre brauchen um die
französische bevölkerung zudem viele
shops ist der gesundheitsminister
kündigte an das tempo werde ab montag
erhöht zahlreiche départements
verlängern der wahl wegen steigender
infektionszahlen die nächtliche
ausgangssperre von 18 bis 8 uhr darf
niemand auf die straße ohne guten grund
rave partys zählen nicht dazu
die kluft zwischen us-präsident jump und
seinen parteifreunden im parlament wird
größer mit den stimmen auch der meisten
republikaner fügte der senat jump eine
heftige niederlage zu über stimmte das
veto des präsidenten gegen das
gesetzespaket zum militärhaushalt aus
washington dritter jäger unerwartet
kehrt der präsident zum jahreswechsel
von seinem domizil in florida zurück ins
weiße haus
doch das neue jahr beginnt für trump mit
einer schweren politischen niederlage
der senat überstimmt sein veto gegen den
verteidigungshaushalt damit stellen sich
auch seine eigenen republikaner in
großer zahl gegen ihn
du wirst du weil dieser abstimmung gibt
es 81 jahr und 13 nein stimmen
zwei drittel der anwesenden senatoren
haben trotz des widerspruchs des
präsidenten zu trump hatte sich gegen
das gesetzespaket gewehrt weil es unter
anderem auch keine stärkere
reglementierung von online plattformen
wie twitter oder facebook vorsah ihnen
wirft er parteilichkeit vor und wittert
nach der entscheidung die republikaner
haben die gelegenheit verpasst die
regelung 230 loszuwerden die großen tech
firmen uneingeschränkte macht gibt
erbärmlich das kräftemessen mit dem
kongress hat trump verloren
ist das nun ein zeichen dass sich seine
republikaner im großen stil von ihm
abwenden nicht unbedingt der
verteidigungshaushalt wird seit
jahrzehnten mit überparteilicher
zustimmung verabschiedet das votum zeigt
aber dass trumps seine partei nicht bzw
nicht mehr so im griff hat wie es häufig
in seiner amtszeit der fall gewesen ist
mit der entscheidung ist nun auch james
geplante abzug von us soldaten aus
deutschland vorerst vom tisch
in den letzten 18 tagen seiner amtszeit
wird er nun wohl an anderer front weiter
kämpfen noch immer gibt er sich
überzeugt dass er um den wahlsieg
betrogen wurde
im atomstreit erhöht iran den druck auf
dem westen das land setze die
internationale atomenergiebehörde
offiziell über ein neues gesetz in
kenntnis dass eine urananreicherung auf
20 prozent vorsieht das wäre deutlich
über dem höchstwert dem das
internationale atom abkommen erlaubt das
hatte us-präsident trump einseitig auf
der reformer in iran aber auch die
europäer hoffen dass der künftige
us-präsident beiden zum atom deal
zurückkehrt neues jahr neue
energiepreise wegen der co2 steuer die
jetzt gilt vor allem beim heizen und
tanken wird es jeder merken so
funktioniert die steuer pro tonne co2
müssen die energieunternehmens 25 euro
bezahlen bis 2025 steigt der preis auf
55 euro an
danach werden die verschmutzungsrechte
versteigert für 55 bis 65 euro pro tonne
ziel ist schritt für schritt von der
fossilen energie weg zu kommen um das
klima zu schützen
david sauer und macken gruppe rechten
schlange stehen um auf den letzten
drücker noch mal günstiger den tank zu
füllen
szenen vom silvestertag in deutschland
es war bekannt mit dem jahreswechsel
wird tanken teurer
im namen des klimaschutzes wie das
ankommt zeigt sich heute in erfurt
ich persönlich finde es nicht gut muss
ich echt sagen bei der spritpreis an
sich selber sowieso auch schon ziemlich
hoch ist aber für mich als fahrer vor
allem vielfahrer ist natürlich jederzeit
anschauen das opfer zusammen mit der
wieder höheren mehrwertsteuer rechnete
adac beim diesel mit einer erhöhung von
11 cent pro liter superbenzin etwa zehn
cent der co2 preis belastet alle die mit
fossiler energie autofahren oder heizen
die bundesregierung will so die
klimaziele erreichen
mit den einnahmen sollen bürger im
gegenzug entlastet werden über die eeg
umlage mit günstigeren strompreisen mit
einer höheren pendlerpauschale und über
fördergelder nicht ausreichend und nicht
sozial sagen kritiker wer nämlich mit
den einnahmen lediglich elektroautos
subventioniert werden oder wärmepumpen
dann bevorzugt man wieder er die reichen
haushalte da aber der steigende co2
preis vor allem die einkommensschwachen
haushalte belastet müssen die auch
besonders kompensiert werden
denn beim heizen kann die steigerung bei
der öl- oder gasrechnung mehr als 100
euro im jahr ausmachen
der umstieg auf e mobilität und
nachhaltige energieversorgung ist 2021
attraktiver geworden
friedrich merz kandidat für den cdu
parteivorsitz lehnt die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen ab die in bosnien
herzegowina gestrandet sind
die eu müsse vor ort helfen sagte er der
funke mediengruppe die katastrophe lasse
sich nicht dadurch lösen so merz dass
wir sagen kommt alle nach deutschland in
bosnien herzegowina waren hunderte
menschen seit tagen in schnee und
eiseskälte aus nachdem ihr zeltlager
lieber und der grenze zu kroatien
abgebrannt war
inzwischen bauen soldaten dort neue
seite auf britta hilpert berichtet es
ist um die null grad heute im camp
lieber in bosnien herzegowina die
flüchtlinge leben in den ruinen eines
camps kein wasser oder strom als heizung
nur das offene feuer unter den mehreren
hundert flüchtlingen verzweiflung einige
verweigern sogar die eine mahlzeit die
man ihnen hier noch gibt don quixote wir
nehmen heute kein essen denn die
polnische regierung hilft uns es gibt
die hätten so viele probleme
deswegen sind wir im hungerstreik die eu
sollte etwas tun
kurz vor weihnachten eskaliert die lage
im camp es brennt nach dem
hilfsorganisationen angekündigt hatten
es so nicht weiter führen zu können
dann kurz vor silvester sollen busse die
migranten in bessere unterkünfte bringen
nach 30 stunden worten müssen sie wieder
aussteigen
denn keiner will sie aufnehmen obwohl
die eu geld für unterkünfte gab und
weiteres verspricht wie hier in bi hat
trotzdem blockieren auch anderswo
anwohner ausweich lager im zerrissenen
bosnien herzegowina verschärft die
flüchtlingsfrage spannungen auch die mit
der eu die idee dass den westbalkan als
abschiebelager oder als
halte lagert migranten will benutzt oder
missbraucht besser gesagt das ist sehr
gefährlich das ist natürlich eine
politische lösung gefährlich auch für
die eu sehr gefährlich für den ruf der
europäischen union etwas
menschenwürdiger ist das lager seit
heute die bosnische armee zelte aufbaute
doch das hilft in der kälte nicht
wirklich die meisten migranten wollen
nicht bleiben sie wollen weiter egal wie
in richtung eu ein arzt sollte viel
wissen über seine patienten über
vorerkrankungen etwa laborbefunde
medikamente behandlungen durch andere
ärzte das ist wichtig im praxisalltag
aber nicht leicht zu gewährleisten
helfen soll die digitalisierung ab jetzt
kann sich jeder gesetzlich versicherte
eine elektronische patientenakte anlegen
lassen
für den gesundheitsminister überwiegen
die vorteile
datenschützer sind skeptisch
erläuterungen vom ralph goldmann und
immer baltes mit diesem video wirbt das
bundesgesundheitsministerium für
akzeptanz in der elektronischen
patientenakte kurzepa können alle daten
zentral digital gespeichert werden
damit haben sie alle ihre
gesundheitsdaten sicher an einem ort und
immer dabei
nirgendwo werde so viel gefaxt wie im
deutschen gesundheitswesen sagte
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn im
sommer das müsse ein ende haben
wir wollen dafür sorgen dass
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen bei
den patientinnen und patienten ankommt
aber auch bei allen die behandeln weil
natürlich auch die behandlung leichter
wird wenn informationen verfügbar sind
die teilnahme ist freiwillig alles soll
zentral in einer app gesammelt werden ob
befunde diagnosen im pfund medikations
pläne oder das bonusheft vom zahnarzt
doch datenschützer warnen man könne im
ersten jahr gar nicht entscheiden welche
dokumente von welchem arzt man frei gibt
entweder alle für alle ärzte oder gar
keine und das anmeldeverfahren
entsprechen noch nicht europäischen
datenschutzstandards sagt der
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte
ich habe jetzt die gesetzlichen
krankenkassen die meiner aufsicht
unterliegen davor gewarnt
eine elektronische patientenakte in
dieser form wäre ein verstoß gegen
europäisches recht
das gesundheitsministerium wies die
bedenken zurück doch viele werden
sicherlich erst einmal zögern ob sie die
elektronische patientenakte in dieser
form überhaupt nutzen werden
ein spaziergang im schnee mit dem
schlitten die piste runter grabe im
shutdown ist diese vorstellung für viele
wohl einfach unwiderstehlich
schon am morgen tummelten sich wanderer
und -roller etwa am brocken im harz
straßen und parkplätze komplett dicht
chaos hoch drei so die polizei ähnlich
groß ist der ansturm auch im taunus der
ruhe über dem schwarzwald die behörden
raten dringend von ausflügen und in
innsbruck liegt auch schnee zum glück
naja zumindest auf der schanze am
bergisel und das ist ja sportlich auch
ganz wichtig dort ist der norweger
halvard agrana rot nach der
qualifikation favorit für das dritte
springen der vierschanzentournee
aber die deutschen springer sind auch
gut dabei die probleme scheinen sie im
griff zu haben
karl geiger und markus eisenbichler
nach schwächeren trainingssprüngen
klappt es in der qualifikation
eisenbichler mit 127 metern und platz 4
wieder im kreis der favoriten auf der
schwierig zu springenden bergisel
schanze gut fürs selbstvertrauen auch
die 125 m das turnier zweiter geiger
platz sieben
der gesamtführende norweger grad
präsentiert sich aber mit einem satz auf
129 meter
unverändert stark springt schon sehr
sehr gut da wird es kann ich auch zu
beweisen morgen mit weiten flügen
richtung innsbruck in der
fußball-bundesliga bleibt union berlin
auswärts ungeschlagen union gewinnt 2 zu
0 in bremen frankfurt leverkusen 2 2 1
hoffenheim freiburg 1 zu 3 arminia
bielefeld gegen gladbach 0 zu 1 und köln
gegen augsburg auch null zu eins die
abendspiele hertha schalke und stuttgart
leipzig ausführlich im aktuellen
sportstudio leverkusen verpasst die
vorübergehende führung leipzig könnte
das am abend gelingen denn die bayern
spielen erst morgen
union berlin muss den
champions-league-platz morgen wieder
abtreten an dortmund oder wolfsburg
dahinter gladbach in der unteren hälfte
bisher nur augsburg gewonnen meinte
schalke bleiben auf jeden fall auf den
abstiegsplätzen
im aktuellen sportstudio ist um 23 uhr
bayer leverkusens trainer peter bosch zu
gast felix loch dominiert weiterhin den
rodel-weltcup der olympiasieger in
berchtesgaden seine führung in der
gesamtwertung ausgebaut
rekord weltmeister felix loch setzt den
siegeszug fort auf seiner heimbahn am
königssee gelingt in der sechste sieg im
siebten rennen
der vorsprung auf den zweitplatzierten
russen roman reptil auf rund eine
viertelsekunde welten im rodeln die
olympia dritte johannes ludwig erreicht
platz drei
toni eggert und sascha benecken melden
sich im kampf um den gesamtweltcup
zurück die weltmeister fangen auf der wm
bahn noch die olympiasieger bendel und
alt ab feiern ihren dritten weltcup sieg
nacheinander
in der gesamtwertung liegen die
österreicher stoller weiterhin vorne
die heute platz drei belegen und mehr
wintersport morgen vielen dank für den
moment macht beim rausgehen in der nacht
kommen schnee und glätte mehr dazu hat
gleich aus dem verlies und heute gibt es
auch wieder ein heute-journal viertel
vor elf mit claus kleber
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen samstagabend bis
morgen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
eine gute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter eine festgefahrene situation ist
dass hier mit dem tief über der adria
was hier feuchte luft nach norden lenkte
und der schnee der in den alpen nach
lässt aber in deutschland kommt neuer
schnee auf und das bereits in den
nächsten stunden
von osten her drängen die schneewolken
ins landesinnere
auch im südwesten und an den alpen
schneit es nach norden gibt es weniger
schnee aber richtung nordsee kann es
regnen und auch einige schneeflocken
sind dabei bei tiefstwerten von minus
fünf grad an den alpen und etwa null
grad nördlich der mittelgebirge also
hier überall frost der schnee bleibt
also auch in tiefen lagen liegen ganz im
norden frostfrei um zwei grad morgen im
tagesverlauf schneit es weiter und zwar
im osten und auch in der mitte und auch
bis nach westen in richtung oder und
neiße kann dann auch regen dabei sein
der kann auch gefrieren im nordwesten
richtung nordsee zeigt sich auch mal die
sonne bei höchsten temperaturen von
minus 2 grad an den alpen und fünf grad
plus an der ostsee die kommenden tage am
montag gibt es weiteren schnee und das
bei temperaturen bei minus zwei bis vier
grad und daran ändert sich bis
mindestens dienstag nichts damit ein
schöner abend